to what made this particular far is so
valuable well it has it has a very
interesting history it's considered like
a masterpiece in the world of Ferraris
it was made for the specific race a
thousand mile race in Italy and then to
go to say mille miglia and for specific
driver it has been driven by oh yeah
that's just a specific driver but
probably the best driver of all time
sorry was that so jose manuel fangio is
probably is considered by most as the
best formula one driver of all time some
may think Schumacher was a better driver
but shumi himself says fond geo is the
best driver of all time so this car is
incredibly special for that reason and
out the fact that he campaigned it if
i'm not mistaken during numerous races
and it never and never crashed it so
most of these Ferraris from the 50s or
60s that that have a real racing
pedigree have been wrecked and rebuilt
this one has not so this is mint
condition essentially yeah I mean it has
been retouched him and it's not it's not
the original there was another Ferrari
in the original condition you really can
see all the beatings that had sustained
it was a very cool car but I mean that
this was not of that I yeah well this
isn't a number one show car so um it's
not I'm sure that they have you know
repainted it it looks like they've
repainted they've touched it up but they
painted it in the original color it's
probably got new rubber for sure on but
probably something close to what fond
geo would have driven himself so it's
basically the original car and I feel
like 28 million dollars all joking aside
is a pretty darn good price for this car
because the record for a Ferrari to
auction is 58 million 38 million a 38
million and and that wasn't a fan geo
car it was not in this car I'm an
interesting things estimate was 28 to 32
and it came right at 22 really i mean
the the price is definite since the
biggest price this year for for a car
and a ferrari Ferraris and there was a
Dennis Joplin Porsche that was recently
sold at auction as well it was yesterday
as well so it was really cute car was
painted all over the psychedelic scenes
from California and if you have pictures
there we go a
and that was she actually drove it every
day sometimes with her dog and use it as
a stage prop so this this this
particular piece attracted a lot of
bidding it was estimated at 400,000 26
oh wow and it sold for 1.8 million
dollars what do you buy this that well
so personally I'm not that into the 356
I love the paint job obviously it looks
really cool and I love Janice it's
ironic because she wanted God to buy her
a mercedes-benz her friends all drove
Porsches and she wanted to make amends
but this is actually the car that she
drove I think Hannah Elliott mentioned
she was driving this like the night
before she died so thats dark right I
didn't mean that very dark it looks cool
it's great I prefer a stone-cold silver
356 frankly and I really would rather
have a metallic finish red car katja
kassin kina thank you so much cardio
colors collectibles for us here a
collectible investing are collecting for
us here at Bloomberg and of course Matt
Miller our resident car guy metallic
cars right I well I mean depends what
card is a Porsche should be silver a
Ferrari should be read Erica you know a
Bugatti should be blue I